1 квітня в Україні стартує медична реформа.
За задумом її авторів, має бути створено ринок
медичних послуг, де державні медустанови
конкуруватимуть між собою за рахунок підвищення
якості обслуговування.
Один із головних принципів медреформи:
що б із вами не сталося, спершу - до сімейного лікаря.
Кожен українець має собі його обрати і підписати
угоду про надання медичних послуг.
У будь-який момент пацієнт може змінити лікаря.
Прив’язки до місця реєстрації немає.
Ви можете обрати спеціаліста, якому довіряєте,
у будь-якому районі міста. У Мінохоронздоров’я
радять якомога швидше визначитися, адже
до одного сімейного лікаря можуть записатися
не більше 1800 пацієнтів. Саме цей лікар буде вас
обстежувати, призначати необхідні аналізи і давати
направлення вже до більш вузьких спеціалістів.
Вакцинація, медичні довідки, лікарняні, рецепти -
це все теж до сімейного лікаря. На першому етапі
медреформи це може створити черги до сімейних
лікарів, хоча й розвантажить профільних.
Кожна українська лікарня, згідно з реформою,
повинна буде приймати пацієнтів
за попереднім записом в електронній медичній
системі. Однак 1 квітня це ще не запрацює:
електронний реєстр впроваджуватиметься
поступово. Найбільше проблем - у селах і
невеличких містах, де бракує комп’ютерів,
немає інтернету, а в багатьох лікарів -
базової комп’ютерної грамотності.
У пілотномурежимі вже тестується система eHealth,
де будутьрозміщені медичні карти пацієнтів та їхні
договори з лікарями. Також автоматизуються
процеси передачі результатів аналізів лікарям
в електронному вигляді. Це означає, що пацієнтам
вже не треба буде їздити особисто за результатами
лабораторних обстежень.
Запроваджується принцип "Гроші йдуть за пацієнтом".
Чим більше пацієнтів у сімейного лікаря,
тим більший його дохід. Держава виділятиме
приблизно 370 гривень на дорослого і 740 -
на дитину чи пенсіонера. Максимально лікар зможе
отримати 62 тисячі гривень на місяць. Але це
не чиста зарплатня. З отриманої суми
ще доведеться сплатити зарплату медсестрі,
закупити медикаменти, медобладнання тощо.
Розподіляти гроші по лікарнях залежно від
прийнятих пацієнтів буде
Національна служба здоров’я. Ідеться загалом про
приблизно 35 мільярдів гривень. Відомство
створили недавно, і поки формується кадровий
склад. У червні Нацслужба здоров'я має підписати
договори з медичними установами і з липня
розпочати перші виплати за надані медпослуги.
Згідно з урядовою програмою "Доступні ліки",
з січня цього року розширено Реєстр
лікарських засобів, вартість яких підлягає
відшкодуванню. Нині у списку 239 препаратів.
Зокрема проти діабету другого типу,
бронхіальної астми, серцево-судинних та інших
захворювань. Отримувати препарати можна
безкоштовно. Для цього потрібно просто показати
в аптеці рецепт від лікаря. Гроші аптека
отримуватиме згодом з держбюджету.